foreign
so I leaned into it I started doing
Frugal February on Instagram yes is it
catching on like wow people are loving
it so we did the no spend challenge in
January no it's been January Frugal
February and as I was looking for ideas
for Frugal February I came across a post
where someone saved 24 deodorant butts
to melt them down into one full stick
so they saved there's a name for the end
of deodorant apparently deodorant butts
is what we're calling them deodorant
butts it's a thing it's a thing like I
could Google that and I wouldn't get
fired or go to the HR office I mean I
don't know
but okay so they saved and so in looking
at Frugal stuff I'm like this person
saved four dollars but wasted a bunch of
time in storage space like that's dumb
yeah I feel like I could have made more
in that time than four dollars exactly
I'm like I would rather you go out and
spend five hours working and make a
hundred bucks then spend five hours
scraping out deodorant from the tube and
trying to make it you know something
something useful a lot of effort so one
of the things I'm saying is like be
smart about how you're being Frugal like
you'll see a lot of things online about
different ways to be frugal and some of
them are good and some of them are dumb
and so trying to discern you know what
is a good Frugal thing to do is
important so I found an article with a
bunch of unusual money saving tips and I
want to get your feedback on them
Georgia not gonna be good I want your
yay or nay okay all right the first one
I actually think is pretty good marry
someone frugal
yay yay number two don't waste money on
toilet paper use newspaper junk mail
bills and more hard pass that is the
hardest nay you can get I'm naying like
a horse over here on that one why no
question newspaper that can't be good
for you hygiene-wise okay what about
this one double your toilet paper by
separating it
no my parents didn't immigrate to this
country for me to use one ply life is
too short and that applies too thin
Christina that's disgusting okay what
about this one limit your toilet paper
usage to two sheets per wipe why are
these all TP related money hacks it's
like they know you
just limiting themselves strong feelings
on toilet paper okay what about this one
cut your own hair no no unless you work
remote and never leave the house
now females maybe can pull it off yeah
maybe I think there's a lot of people
post covid better yay on that I can't
just like take a flow beat to this
Christina this is it's a it's a Leonardo
DaVinci I mean it's a sculpture
you have very specialized hair I will
admit that I don't know that I could do
that all right this is a Michelangelo
next one is to plant fake flowers in
your garden they last for years require
no maintenance and are in full bloom in
the winter I would argue just don't do
any of that and just don't have plants
if you're not gonna plant them you look
so horrified I don't think you're HOA
okay with a fake house plant inside I
can get behind that okay for the looks
what about okay this next one is one
man's trash is another man's treasure it
says there's no shame in going through
the neighbor's trash once it's been
placed outside for collection it's
public domain and you can pick up some
great things that other people just
don't want or need anymore if I saw my
neighbor going through my trash I would
be calling the cops immediately so don't
do that on George's problem don't even
try it that's got to be against HOA
rules in my neighborhood disgusting what
are you looking for in someone's trash
I mean I'm not gonna lie there's been a
few times where I passed some trash on
the road and saw like something there's
like a TV on the curb and you think you
can fix it up that's one thing but to go
through their filthy garbage to hope you
find something no yeah that's rough okay
this one says take a vacation quote
unquote at Christmas to save money on
gifts just let everyone know you're
going away for the holidays and we'll
exchange gifts when you return then lay
low buy all your presents in the after
Christmas sales for way less and have a
very happy New Year
so this is their money hack flee the
country and let your family forget about
you never have to buy my gift again hey
but you'll get a good sale after
Christmas insane okay what about this
one cover your floor with carpet samples
how about that for your new house it
says you can pick them up cheap and
sometimes free
um at hardware stores just put them in
squares and glue them down just random
loose samples all over the floor I guess
I care too much about aesthetic and my
own quality of life to do that okay I'm
above that you're above that okay uh
this one's really strange I think this
one I'm just gonna go ahead and say it's
an a before I read it but donate your
clothes then buy them back the local
charity will clean them for you and you
can just pop back in a week buy the ones
you want for a few bucks it's cheaper
than a dry cleaner
okay the idea that me buying my clothes
back after I gave them for free is a
money hack might be the stupidest one on
this list so far
and also you're hoping they clean them
right you've been to Goodwill that smell
ain't the smell of freshly dry cleaned
clothes
so true okay if you jumped on the hair
back bandwagon and you're cutting your
own hair how about this one
old hair makes great stuffing for
pillows
I might throw up on air for the first
time
take old hair and stuff it into a pillow
don't cut your
the local barber shop or hair salon
give you the cuttings from the floor
listen BuzzFeed has gone too far it's
soft free and biodegradable
I like cringe so hard at that one I cut
my own hair and I'm still not gonna
sleep on it like Ugh okay the last one
let's end on a decent one it's flesh
with less water place a common house
brick inside a plastic bag and seal it
repeat the seal with another bag just to
make it super waterproof because you
don't want brick corrosion put this in
your toilets tank and it will save you
money on your water bill over yours I'm
not I'm not doing any of this I don't
think plumbers would agree I think it's
probably bad for your your plumbing
system in your toilet to do things like
that there's probably a reason why the
tank is that size yeah I'm gonna go with
I don't know just I'd rather get a side
hustle versus do any of this insane
stuff
just budget I'd rather cut a
subscription than have to use my own
hair in a pillow
crunch so bad and I think it's so
important to highlight because I have
seen so many people trying to save money
and doing it in unwise ways there are
great ways to do it that you know it's
worth the investment and there are other
times where it's probably best to just
get a side hustle listen I love the
Amish but I'm not making my own soap
anytime soon you sure I'm not doing it
well but the thing is too is like
there's actually side hustles that you
can create that you know you make soap
for other people and it makes money you
want to make your fancy soaps yeah the
Old Goat soap
soap oh my God